der weltraum den sie schneller aus als
vermutet forscher haben jetzt
verblüffendes über die ausdehnung
geschwindigkeit des weltalls
herausgefunden alles über das
expandierende über das schneller
expandierende universum jetzt bei klick
zum science fiction breitet sich also
der weltraum schneller aus als gedacht
das wollen forscher jetzt mit hilfe des
hubble-weltraumteleskops festgestellt
haben aber erstmal zur ausbreitung an
sich der russische astrophysiker
alexander friedmann beschrieb ein sich
aus denen das weltall erstmals im januar
22 der belgische astrophysiker georgi
lemaitre machte die entdeckung der
expansion sein bekannter in dem er auch
einige entdeckungen anderer forscher zur
untermauerung einwand lemaitre ist
übrigens auch an der entstehung der
urknalltheorie beteiligt gewesen
laut dieser hat sich die ausdehnung des
universums ein paar milliarden jahre
nach dem urknall verlangsamt allerdings
hat die geschwindigkeit seitdem wieder
ordentlich zugelegt das kann eigentlich
nicht sein denn die gravitation sollte
die ausbreitung weiter verlangsamen
verantwortlich für diese zunahme soll
die dunkle energie seien die jetzt
erstmal eine hypothese ist und für die
es noch keine hinreichende definition
gibt diese dunkle energie soll der
gravitation entgegenwirken und sie soll
rund 68 prozent der gesamtenergie im
weltall ausmachen bisher waren forscher
davon ausgegangen dass sich das
universum mit einer geschwindigkeit von
67 15 kilometern pro sekunde pro
megaparsec ausdehnt das ist die hubble
konstante das heißt galaxien die ein
megaparsec voneinander entfernt sind das
sind 32 6 millionen lichtjahre sich mit
dieser geschwindigkeit voneinander
entfernen
doch diese konstante ist falsch das hat
eine überprüfung dieser konstante mit
dem hubble weltraumteleskop ergeben auf
diesen neuen messungen liegt die hubble
konstante bei 73 2 kilometern pro
sekunde pro megaparsec und ist damit
rund 9 prozent höher als bisher
angenommen in zehn milliarden jahren
sind demnach alle objekte im all doppelt
so weit voneinander entfernt als heute
jetzt haben forscher der esa also mit
hilfe der satelliten dario mlp und
planck und des weltraumteleskops habe
herausgefunden dass sich das anscheinend
schneller
den 9 schneller als bisher angenommen
dazu haben die wissenschaftler mit
hubble die entfernung und die
rotverschiebung von 2.400 veränderlichen
sternen so genannten c frieden und 3000
supernovae gemessen
die satelliten hingegen wurden
eingesetzt um die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung zu messen photonen
im mikrowellenbereich eigentlich hätten
sich diese werte decken müssen
zitat des forschers adam ries man
beginnt mit der messung gleichzeitig an
zwei gegenüberliegenden messpunkten die
so entstehenden linien müssen sich
erwartungsgemäß in der mitte treffen
wenn die daten stimmen
doch sie trafen sich nicht ganz in der
mitte und wir wollten herausfinden warum
das so ist zitat ende
die forscher nehmen als bild für ihre
forschungsergebnisse den bau einer
brücke über ein tal
man startet auf beiden seiten aber die
beiden teile treffen sich nicht der
mitte in der physik ist das fatal
irgendwas stimmt nicht mit der hubble
konstante die daten lassen sich nicht
mit den älteren theorien über die
expansion des weltalls vereinbaren
entweder die dunkle energie ist ziemlich
seltsam und gewinnt im laufe der zeit an
kraft oder sie hat bisher unbekannte
eigenschaften oder es gab im universum
zu beginn unbekannte subatomare teilchen
von denen wir noch nichts wissen oder
und das würde alles verändern
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie ist
nicht vollständig eins ist aber sicher
irgendwas fehlt glaubt ihr dass uns bald
gelingen wird hinter das geheimnis von
dunkler energie und dunkler materie zu
kommen schreibt mir eure theorie zum
thema weltall in die kommentare falls
euch das video gefallen hat klar einen
daumen nach oben das denn da und
abonniert den kanal ist ja vollkommen
kostenlos kast kostet nichts erfährt
lediglich wann das nächste video kommt
und empfiehlt uns gerne weiter wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video bis dann bleibt
dran